We always hear about our qualities from people
around us who compare us with
our parents.
We find people usually saying things like,
she has got her excellent
drawing skills from her dad or her beautiful
singing is inherited from her mom!
These are the qualities we inherit from our
parents, and which are present since
birth.
But there are several qualities which an individual
develops in their lifetime,
depending on interests and needs.
Like developing certain abilities, learning
new
languages, and so on.
This happens gradually, over a period of time
as and when new interests or needs
are encountered.
This analogy can be used to study the types
of Immunity in humans!
Yes!
We have got introduced to the two major types
of Immunity in the previous
video.
These are Innate and Acquired immunity.
Let us get into the details of
these types now!
We will begin our journey by learning about
the innate immunity first.
The term
“innate” means “inborn”, or “congenital”.
That is, “innate” here stands for being
present since birth.
So is this type of immunity present in the
organism since
birth?
Yes!
All humans are born with an innate ability
to fight off infections.
This
type of immunity is called Innate immunity.
And since it is present by birth, the
type is not specific to any particular infection.
Rather, it is a non-specific type.
That means, the ability helps the body fight
various acute infections on its own.
Now to fight the invading antigens, the system
has to be prepared with some
strong armed forces.
Right?
In this case, the innate immunity has a few
components that help it perform the
necessary tasks.
These include the physical barriers of the
body, physiological
barriers, the cells of the immune system and
a few other important molecules.
Let
us glance at these once!
The first on our list are the Physical barriers.
We say that innate immunity is the
one with which we are born.
So the physical barriers will include all
the organs, or
their secretions which help us fight infections.
Can you cite an example for me?
Yes!
The largest human organ, that is the SKIN,
acts as the first line of defence for
the human body.
So this physical barrier is an excellent example
of the innate
immunity.
Similar to the skin, there are several other
physical barriers like the
mucous coatings on the respiratory, the urogenital
and the gastrointestinal tract.
On similar lines, we have physiological barriers
and cellular barriers as well.
The
Physiological barriers include the obstacles
for the foriegn invaders like, acids
present in the stomach, saliva secreted by
the salivary glands and many more.
And do we know what cellular barriers are?
Yes !The immune cells like the
lymphocytes and monocytes, form the cellular
barriers, as the invaders have to
face them as soon as they enter the body.
Now which are the other molecules that we
had mentioned?
Well, we know that
the immune cells are capable of producing
target specific proteins called
antibodies against the invaders.
The various types of antibodies can be grouped
as the molecules produced for fighting off
the infections.
Now since all the components, that is the
physical barriers, the physiological ones
and the immune cells are present in our body
right since birth, they are
categorised as the components of Innate immunity.
Now that we have learnt about the innate immunity
which is the first type of
immunity, let’s move ahead with the second
type.
The next type is Acquired immunity.
Here, as the name suggests, the immunity is
acquired by the individual in due course of
time!
It is a type of immunity which is developed
over a period of time and is highly
specific in nature.
And how does immunity develop gradually with
time?
I mean, we understand the
fact that we are born with some ability to
fight infections naturally, as it happens
in case of innate immunity.
But how can immunity of some specific type
be
developed?
Let us understand that with an example!
People these days love to ride their bikes
without wearing a helmet.
But that is
definitely not a safe option!
But if a person comes across any unfortunate
accident, then a lesson for lifetime
is learned from it!
Over a period of time, the person develops
a fear for the unfortunate happening
and learns how to take precautions to avoid
it!
Same is the case with our acquired immunity!
There are numerous microbes present around
us.
They constantly find an
opportunity to enter our body.
Thus, our body has to encounter numerous
pathogenic microbes constantly.
These encounters help our body to develop
strategies to fight these invaders.
And
this is how immunity is developed against
specific pathogens that attack us!
And
this type of immunity keeps developing over
our lifetime, as we keep
encountering several invaders.
This is nothing but Acquired immunity.
One of the simplest examples of Acquired immunity
is that of Chicken pox
infection.
The chicken pox virus will act as the antigen
and our body will
synthesize antibodies against it as an immune
response.
Chicken pox virus → Antigen
Body synthesizes Antibodies → Immune response
Our immune system has a very effective memory
also known as immunological
memory!
So once the antibodies against that particular
virus are synthesized,
then next time the body will recognize the
same antigen and destroy it, before it
can cause any sought of infection.
This is how the acquired immunity works!
Now that we have got introduced to it, let
us get into the details and types of
Acquired immunity in the next video!